écoutez je voudrais d'abord dire à
françois patriat que j'aime beaucoup que
la république en marche qui prétend
faire de la politique autrement et bien
faire la politique autrement c'est pas
faire comme on le fait sur tous les
plateaux télé depuis des décennies ne
pas reconnaître qu'on s'est pris un
échec pour ne pas dire une gamelle
killip mars que parce que
moi je suis pas dit notre collègue
parler de d'estimations à plus 60 sièges
je crois même que que juste après les
législatives on dirait que le groupe la
république en marche pourrait avoir 90
yens qui a dit ça après on est passé à
60 après on est à 50 et aujourd'hui on
est en négatif et je suis je suis étonné
que françois patriat qui incarne dans
cette maison la république en marche
c'est à dire le nouveau monde c'est à
dire la politique autrement ne dise pas
oui c'est un échec et il nous explique
que c'est un succès donc je trouve que
le nouveau monde aujourd'hui il
ressemble curieusement à l'ancien monde
pour pas dire à la préhistoire